I have said many times as have all of my
predecessors that France is America's
oldest friend our first ally and during
our darkest hours that fact rings truer
than ever it was true and Lafayette
crossed the Atlantic some 238 years ago
to help Americans achieve Liberty it was
true in 1917 when general Pershing's
army arrived in France to join the
Allied front and his aide proclaimed
Lafayette we are here it was true in
World War two when America joined the
courageous fighters of the French
Resistance in opposing and defeating the
greatest evil the world has ever known
and certainly it was to 14 years ago in
the wake of the sep tember 11th attacks
New York Pennsylvania Washington lemans
front page read new son to sandakan we
are all Americans and it became clear at
that moment that our centuries long
relationship had evolved into even more
the United States and France were not
only friends we're family and today the
entire world joins our family in
heartbreak yet again don't mistake what
these attacks represent this is not a
clash of civilizations these terrorists
have declared war against all
civilization they killed Yazidis because
they are you z DS they kill Christians
because they are Christians they kill
Shia because they are Shia and on they
rape and torture and pillage and call it
the will of God they are in fact
psychopathic monsters and there is
nothing nothing civilized about them so
this is not a case of one civilization
pitted against another this is a battle
between civilization itself and
barbarism between civilization and
medieval and modern fascism both at the
same time and that is why every single
nation state in the region and around
the world is opposed to dash and so the
violence the terror the senseless murder
of 132 people and injuring of hundreds
more including four Americans this is an
assault not just on France but coming on
the heels of brutal attacks in Lebanon
Iraq and elsewhere it is an assault on
our collective sense of reason and
purpose an attack on civility itself and
I want to thank the men and women who
bravely reported to the scene of the
attacks and those who continue to work
around the clock to heal the injured
restore calm and provide relief among
those who died on Friday night was an
American student Nohemi Gonzalez Noemi
had come to Paris for the same reasons
that so many Americans do and have for
centuries to expand her horizons enrich
her education and experience the magic
of this city as one of our former
classmates put it no Amy's death the
world lost such a beautiful shining
light now I understand the sadness of
those who knew no Emmy and other victims
the world is diminished by their deaths
and no words of comfort or sorrow or
even resolve can change that we don't
have the power to bring them back so we
must do instead what is within our power
and that begins with a sense of fierce
solidarity among good and decent people
everywhere with the vow that we will
never be intimidated by terrorists
and with a promise that we will never
allow these murderers to achieve their
violins no one should doubt that the
light still shines in the city of light
and the darkness will not ever never
overpower it as history records Paris
has known even darker moments and it has
overcome them the people of Paris joined
by their friends partners and family
across the globe will stand up for and
live by the values that light the world
the underlying principles that form the
backbone of our laws and the essence of
our common humanity the pursuit of
justice and the embrace of peace the
belief in the dignity and the worth and
the rights of every human being liberté
egalité a fraternity tonight the u.s.
embassy in Paris joins the many other
landmarks around the world shining the
blue glow huge lights of the French
Republic we do so as a reminder to the
brave people of France that your
American sisters and brothers will stand
with you shoulder to shoulder as we have
stood together throughout history
tonight we are all Parisians and as the
old motto of this resilient city says
and does Parisians have painted across
the social media in recent days flick to
a neck murga tour buffeted but not sunk
we will not let our sorrow for the loss
of life overcome us we will not lose
sight of all the good that we are
working together to do we will not
change our course or cancel our plans
including our plans to come together in
Paris later this month for the UN
climate conference
and President Obama told me today how
much he looks forward being here being
part of that important moment ultimately
we will defeat dash and all who share
their despicable ideology and we are on
the course to do so we will continue
also the show compassion to those who
seek refuge from the violence that the
terrorists and gender we will fight to
ensure that the world that our children
inherit is richer in love and shorter on
hate we will work to bring like knowing
me Gonzalez a beautiful shining light to
areas places that are couched in
darkness that's our responsibility
that's our duty and we will do our duty
side by side and we will prevail new van
caval dash a tu sukhi potash some
ideology meet Prasad a new continued LOL
mokh Raider compassion or ver Sookie
shesh refuge free on idea low social a
dar lative of east new new back home of
Lycia nozipho a monkey saw a blue leash
damu my complete then they come no Amy
Gonzalez news illuminare own late
enabler damn man ii thik hai o de soleil
sinatra d'ivoire a news alone larceny
ensemble a new news on softie ha thank
our next I beaucoup de ella vive la
France